[Music]
known for his soulful baritone voice
powerful melodies and engaging lyrics
Bill Withers music has stood the test of
time it's inspired generations from R&B
rap and soul and has been played in
films commercials and of weddings
throughout the world even health care
workers choirs and artists were inspired
by his uplifting lyrics during the
corona virus pandemic born William
Harrison withers jr. he grew up in slab
fork West Virginia after school he
joined the Navy for nine years before
becoming a milkman and then a factory
worker
between shifts he taught himself to play
guitar that he bought from a pawn shop
see me my grandma on this day a demo
tape he recorded landed in the hands of
an executive at Sussex Records in 1971
one of the first songs they recorded
would be a hit
ain't no sunshine one in a Grammy Award
ain't no sunshine when she's gone with
us joined Columbia Records in 1975 ten
years after his first Grammy he won
another for a song he recorded with
Grover Washington Jr just the two of us
[Music]
he won his third Grammy for a recording
of lean on me in 1987
when you're not snow
songs out of the music business like
beef is to the hamburger business you
know if you don't have a song that
that's where it all starts withers will
also be known as the soul man who turned
his back on Fame in 1985 he quit singing
and retreated from public life he'd
released just eight Argon's said I could
be his assistant hard lazy player he
made a quip that he told someone he was
Bill with us and they didn't believe him
but he did make a rare appearance when
he was inducted into the Hall of Fame in
2005
[Music]
one live this many say it was the
honesty in his lyrics that made so many
connect with his music